[Music]
this
thing that's inside of me
it's mean he looks like a man
that don't be full he is as far
from human as they come
monsterland is a series of monster
stories that are about really broken
people who through encounters with
monsters of all varieties go through
their hurdles and come out on the other
side somehow changed
i think the show asks us to ask
ourselves
if we can ever really escape who we are
or combat our inner monster
sometimes you have to live
with what you've done in order to live
the book is beautiful nathan ballinger
the author is
an incredible writer and i read the
first short story
uh which ended up being our pilot and
thought that it was so
incredible i called my age and said
right away i have to do this
we worked our way through the book and
we decided which stories were the most
relevant and which characters we really
responded to the most
how do we get rid of it we kill it
i hope that people will see being human
isn't about being good or bad
and that good people sometimes make
really bad decisions and that that is
okay because the human struggle is so
terrific i can just
feel the claws in my brain no not
tonight no
tonight was fun kate
hey there's lightness and darkness i
think in the show and also just in life
so i think where we really really
balance that very well all of our
characters have
been living and gotten to a place where
they're broken and they've been through
something and they need
help and that's i think the way that
being human is
i've given them monsters to help them
move through those roadblocks